okay i wanted to provide an update for
the strawberry varieties
for the state strawberry is probably the
the second most popular crop in the
state uh second to peaches
but uh and there has been increased
interest
in production of strawberries but for a
variety of reasons
um we've there's been some a bit of
uh hesitancy amongst the growers for one
it's
cited as being too difficult or
expensive
and uh you know in having made all of
the investment
uh there still may not uh be the
production of a of a
of a uh crop in order to make a profit
so as we know the
most the the best way to ensure
a viable crop is to plant
just to plant the varieties that are
well adapted
first of all to use crops that are well
adapted and varieties or cultivars
within that crop
that are well adapted to the area so
there's there's great need in
technological advancements
and variety selection variety
development be that strawberry or
regards of the crop that you're growing
and there are few with document with the
documented adaptability to our area
camaros is the big variety that we have
is
it has global adaptability um but
uh but there are it does have its issues
there is just a need for
other varieties and um varieties
are the most one of the most important
decisions that
you're going to make in variety in
crop production
so the objective of this study and all
of our variety trials is to improve
strawberry production
by introducing new better adapted
strawberry varieties
to improve the especially crop market in
the state
and i want to start off by providing a
list of the varieties we looked at 12
varieties
this trial has been going on um
for about five years not not with all of
the same varieties here
but we have our albion which is a day
neutrals
only day neutral in the trial this year
again camarosa
developed by uc davis and our
and camino real which is a variety that
growers are becoming familiar with this
year because
camarosa wasn't available camarosa is
our market standard
uh it wasn't uh is available this year
so many growers had to
uh depend on camino real and um
i will talk about how it's done in
chandler our other variety
our other our former
market standard and you can see some of
the others uh one i wanted to mention
rocco and liz those are two that were
developed by nc state
um great uh glad to have those in again
this year
uh just to give you an idea of what we
did
we experimental plots that we had they
were all replicated
four times and uh each experimental
experimental plot was about 20 feet long
and that contained about 34 plants
per plot which resulted in a
in a per acre plant number of about
over 12 000 and we planted these on the
23rd
of october and of last year and
planted on double staggered rose and
again
23 12 000 plants per acre
randomized complete block design you can
see our
our double staggered row uh hole puncher
hole punching wheel there they also as
the holes are being punched into the
plastic
there's also some water with a little
bit of
fertilizer entering the planting hole as
well
we harvested this year we harvested
between
april 7th and may 18th we harvested 12
times
we did use row covers back prior to the
event our freeze event in february 15th
and those covers remained on the
strawberries for about two weeks and
uh this is you here are results
uh this is looking at the total
marketable yield
uh per acre for our our strawberries and
as you can see
uh camarosa as we would expect is still
up towards the top but we have a new
variety
at least new to us fronteras
it's a variety that was produced by uc
davis and
it was did pretty well this year and i
i would like to be able to include in
our trials next year
and again our camp camino real the
variety that
a number of our growers had to depend on
this year uh did
did quite well it was very comparable to
camarosa
as in previous years
but we look at the rocco the rock the
yield of rocco
is it's it's a little bit diminished
when compared to the others
but rocco was bred to be an early
variety and it is
uh uh it was meant to be a replacement
for sweet charlie
and uh it it it does uh does quite well
it it
has the the production of something
that's on par with camarosa for that
time of the season
and another important variable we looked
at is the
uh individual berry weight as you can
see fronteras again it was the number
one
yielder and uh fronteras was the largest
berry
uh the mean size of the berry was at 20
little over 27 almost 27 and a half
grams
per berry and uh that's a that's a
pretty large berry and that's not the
largest berry
of course we had some large it ranged
from
a little bit over uh 30 grams uh
maybe 33 grams i think
some of the larger berries that we saw
there
and then we can we notice our our market
standard
camarosa at 21.5 grams
now followed by camino real at 19.8 on
roughly almost 20 grams
for fruit and i was a little bit uh a
little bit
surprised that uh camino real came in at
that
uh at that size because early on it
looked it appeared that camino real was
producing
some pretty large berries consistently
so
but the the data doesn't lie so there
you have it
um but uh out of all of those varieties
what i wanted to do is focus on
on our overall top performers and that's
again our market standard camino
camarosa
and camino real which is gaining in
popularity
and fronteras and i didn't mention ruby
june that's another variety that a lot
of growers
uh are are interested in uh it's been my
opinion that uh you know a number of the
growers either love ruby june or
or hate it and but i think it is growing
in popularity
uh i don't have it pictured here but
we'll discuss that after
and just wanted to have this graph here
really just to show you uh what happened
during the season
and uh you know where were these yields
you know in um according to the weeks of
harvest
and so you can see we had a or at least
we were it appeared that we were coming
off of a peak
uh uh at the our first harvest april 7th
um and we
and it's really odd this year because we
had a we had a really
big start and we never really recovered
in our trials
uh we did have a peak another peak as
you can see
uh we so after that harvest we had a
uh just a really pretty significant
decline
and all of the varieties perform that
trended that way and you can see the
um the dotted line here is our
average average yield for across all
berries
and um camino real and the gray
and i hope you can see these these these
colors here these lines but
and fronteras and uh
camino ria camarosa you can see camarosa
appears to be a little bit earlier than
fronteras
and uh and it's comparable to fronteras
in marketable yield
and again camille riyal it is
more similar i i'd suppose to camerosa
in terms of
of earliness
and i also wanted to take a look at what
was going on during the week
as we as is pretty common or pretty
typical
is that we start off with some big
berries and
as the season progresses we the berries
start to tend
uh towards the smaller berries and
that's because we
when we start our primary flowers when
we begin
those are larger flowers and so larger
flowers typically mean a larger berry
and we can see that the berries started
off
here and we did actually see somewhat of
a peak
in the berry size but it did again it
did
start to trend down to smaller berries
as we
as we approach the end of our our
harvests
so i wanted to focus on specific
varieties and this is fronteras
it produces really large berries conical
shaped berries
uh the largest berry that we had as i
mentioned was about 32 grams
uh the the uh the maturity
is a little bit later than camarosa
the plant size in in terms of the plant
the plant is similar in size to camarosa
uh the camarosa does have a it's a large
plant
and the berries the berries sort of had
a
uh almost for lack of a better word
that the the the color of the redness
was
almost it tended to be a little bit
fluorescent red it was uh
just a kind of an extra brilliant red it
can't really
it wasn't really captured in this
picture right here uh but we
you really see it in the uh you really
see it in the field
uh it is a sweet berries it was a pretty
pleasant berry
pretty taste a pretty pleasant tasting
berry uh it had a little bit of tartness
now moving on to camino riyal the
variety that the growers had to depend
on this year
uh and the uh out of all the growers i
think
one was not completely satisfied with
camino real
i've heard after that other than that
i've heard nothing but good things about
the variety it is a large it produces a
large berry
typically and that kind of probably
seems to suggest to me that
uh what we were seeing in the field and
the numbers that we're actually getting
for the berry size
uh that may suggest that we have quite a
bit of variability in the
in the and the very individual berry
size
uh but so as i mentioned it really seems
to in the field that really seemed to
produce some
fairly large berries consistently
and it is a berry that is similar
camarosa
and uh you know it was favorable to most
growers and it has a pretty a fairly
pleasant taste one of the
the downsides of this berry is that uh
and the growers really didn't point this
out that they they were
quite pleased with it but it has a
reputation for
not being quite as flavorful not being
quite as sweet as some of the others
but we found that you can improve uh
that if
the berries are are harvested when
they're uh really red
but uh you know this is it's not very
pretty not a simple thing to do really
when you're in the field especially in a
you pick operation
uh when customers are you know they're
finding red berries and they and they
picked them
but if this berry is left on the plant a
little bit longer you can
improve on the sweetness and the flavor
of the berry
uh that brings us to camarosa it had a
maximum berry size of a 22
and a half uh it was the
top yielder again this year
and it has a pretty an excellent flavor
it's if you can match it there are
some in the trials that have surpassed i
think camarosa
in flavor but it does have an excellent
flavor
and it is a excellent yielder a fairly
consistent yielder
it's usually in the tops every year and
that's that's why it's the market
standard
and the the added variety i
wanted to talk about was ruby june it
was
a variety of much discussion early on as
i said
at least early on a lot of the growers
they either
loved it or they hated it we think that
there's probably something to do
with uh fertility so varieties
vary in terms of
of their nutrient uh requirements
particularly
nitrogen and so these might be a higher
feeder or it may not require as much
nitrogen
under but there there is developing
information out there on varieties
and their um their nutrient requirements
this is a variety bred by lesson canyon
and this is uh i mean it is
i i think it's a fairly good variety it
is slightly earlier than camaros in our
trials
and one thing about this berries uh the
plant at least
it's a medium-sized plant but the
it has a tendency to produce these
really large fan
type leaves and that's one of the things
that
sort of stuck out to me the berry is a
very
good tasting variety it was i found it
to be very sweet
a very flavorful berry and some of the
growers
expressed the same the same things in
terms of the
quality of ruby june oops
so well that brings us to the end of the
presentation
and if you have any questions i'd be
happy to entertain them
you